[Music]  like you portray yourself as someone  who's yeah just in it for the publicity  and then you're gone yeah  fire drill fire alarm fire alarm let's  sort a commercial and figure out what  we're gonna do  because the fire department loves when i  get to the plug before we evacuate  that's my people by the way jeff ross  he just informed me that the fire alarm  is not for this area right here we are  fine we're finding out what it's for but  everybody's perfectly safe so let's stay  here  and now james van der beek's gonna sing  a song  it's what  is it really  it's burnt popcorn in the nurses station  what the hell is that all about  oh  oh that's sad because protocol in an  emergency is to take everyone out for  flapjacks  19 years ago today we debuted yeah and  20 years ago today you were a hopeless  addict  [Applause]  man  oh he's back look his hands shaking it's  our 19th year on the air  and you're here for the dumbest one  we've ever done  [Music]